Hi, this is Eric, and I'm Joni Hansen, and this is our daughter, Stephanie Hansen.
And when she was 12 years old, she was diagnosed with an incurable cancer that the medical
world didn't have a protocol for.
So this is a Stephanie, and she'll kind of give you a little, how this kind of journey
started.
Hi, so at age 12, I went to the hospital thinking I had appendicitis, but soon realized
that after many scans that I had cancer, it was crazy to think that I could ever get cancer.
But with the help of my parents and doctors and nurses, they helped me to get where I
am today, a survivor.
She's amazing.
It hasn't been a fun journey or easy journey, but it is a journey that you definitely can do
and succeed if you are, well, we all love the Lord.
We trust 100% on God's direction and His guidance, so we prayed and prayed, and when
she was diagnosed at the hospital, the doctor came in and said, yep, there's a tumor on
her bladder, and yes, that means cancer.
So that stopped us in our tracks, lots of tears right away, and after we, but in that nanosecond
of time, that only God did, He said, resist the spirit of fear.
And He showed me what fear does is it grips your heart, and it renders you paralyzed and
ineffective.
And there is no way that I was going to be ineffective for my baby.
And also He showed me at that same time that what fear does, it causes confusion and anger,
bitterness, confusion, and division was the last one, and it was the division that hit
me to the heart.
And then after we hugged and we prayed, it's definitely locked out in the hallway.
And Eric came out, and the first thing out of his mouth was, we are going to fight this
as a united front, we are not going to be divided.
And so just knowing that we had that assurance right away, right as the diagnosis was put
out there, we knew we were going to be okay.
No matter how it ended up, we knew the Lord was in control.
And at that point, I continued to say, you know, people would say, aren't you mad at God?
Different things like that?
And don't you wonder why?
And I'd say, I can't ask why, because God is sovereign and I am not.
And no reason is good enough for this mama to have this happen to her baby.
So and Eric said, right from the time of diagnosis, I am expecting God to show us glory through
this, no matter how, what the end result is, because we didn't know.
So with that, we ended up in oncology, and we had a double hickman installed, found out
it.
She had a tumor removed for her bladder, and it was the first operation and only operation
she had, which was really good.
And we did not, the medical world had no cure for her.
So that's when we began our journey to find out what we should do, and we pursued a lot
of different avenues, and a lot of people had a lot of advice for us, and we put them
in basically a box until we had as much information as we could, and then we prayed about it, and
we were led to Dr. Connor's clinic, and the protocol that he had, and it was VIA, one
of our friends whose daughter, he was able to help here, and so we already had a contact
that there was a success with cancer, and so we were very excited and optimistic.
So when we came for our first consultation, it was just Eric and I, after he had examined
to Stephanie, and she went out in the lobby, and so Eric and I are just, this is really
cool.
Yeah, this is really cool.
So Eric and I are sitting there, and then, so he knows the history what's going on, and
he didn't know what we had been telling people or anything, and then he shares about himself
and he was talking about, he said, I am not the healer, God is the healer, and it's hard
when people come in, so you need to heal me, you need to heal me, he goes, God is sovereign,
I am not, and I almost fall off my chair, because he didn't know that that's what I was saying,
and then he continued to say, and it's God that gets the glory through this, no matter
how what the outcome is, if you allow them, and that was exactly what Eric had been saying.
So when we walked out, we were like, we know this is where the Lord is directing us for
this protocol, and so we jumped in, full guns, and didn't worry much about what we were
going to look like as far as financial, because when you are praying, and you're connected,
and not divided, you got to just really trust that the Lord will provide, because it's not
a want, it's a need, and at that point, that's what God promises, I will provide for your
needs, and we needed something for our little girl, and so that's what brought us here, and
that's what helped us sign on the dotted line, so to say, but it's just great because
the other forms of protocol, that they were trying, the medical world was trying to give
us, or would give her two other forms of cancer, that was a side effect, and that's like, not
okay.
Yeah, not okay, so, anyway, so she's strong and healthy, she's now 17, and just
doing really well, so that's wonderful.
Yeah, so any other specific questions?
You know, thanks so much, you guys did such a great job, thank you so much for sharing,
we really appreciate it, but we really appreciate the staff here and Dr. Conner's, and that there's
hope for those that aren't given hope, and go on, one other thing, is like with natural paths
and this natural way, it's hard sometimes, because people don't understand it, and it's
against the grain, but one of the things that I tell people is, as far as side effects and
negative side effects, really the only negative side effect is that it wouldn't help, it's not
going to cause something else, or destroy her body via chemicals and things like that,
the only thing that it's going to do is just not affect it, then there's other things
that you can do, so with like medical bills ramping up, you know, it's, you really need to
weigh the pills and the cons, you're going to be spending anyway, but what are you doing
to your body in the meantime?
So the natural way is the way that we would go, even if something new came up with my health
or aerosol, or any other other kids, is that would be the choice we would invest our
resources in what's natural, because it's not going to hurt us in a long picture, so we
think it's the way to go, yeah, very good, thank you so much.